bio devancé squeeze aujourd'hui on se
retrouve sur fight night hatfield 10,2
le voilà enfin [ __ ] et paraît qu'il
est encore plus flippant et plus
oppressant que le premier on va décéder
c'était mes explications très claires de
ce jeu très saine au le control to use
flash lite ok là y'a des lumières sur
les côtés agréable qui a parlé en
anglais pendant trois nuits pour
m'expliquer je ferai un petit résumé si
j'arrive à regarder ces trois mois s'ils
sont là où fin de dos pour le moment ils
sont mignons on a presque envie de les
caresser délicatement comme ça ils sont
mignons et pâques pitié ils vont nous
défoncer croyez moi les une boîte à
musique dans cette salle apparemment
watts c'est quoi ça ok je sais pas aya
plus le lapin il est parti ou à cesser
bon chic on est juste là c'est juste la
caméra quand on voit la halle et savard
au territoire et à beaucoup plus de
trucs à faire que dans un look est alors
en fait d'aucun autre petite cabine
voilà on a accès à toutes les caméras de
surveillance pour ceux qui n'ont pas
mieux la vie des australiens après 10,1
et ces trois monstres vont se déplacer
est la base ils volent me défoncer voilà
en gros et du coup dans un lac aux
arrivées jusqu'à moins y avait des
portes qu'on pouvait fermer pour les
empêcher d'accéder à moi mais là y'a
plus de portes
y a plus de porte et en face il ya un
gros trou et on a une lampe torche pour
moi ce qui arrive et on peut se mettre
un masque pour faire semblant d'être
l'un des leurs ok bon ben voilà on est
prêt c'est parti via cette [ __ ] de
boîte à musique
apparemment il faut la laisser tout le
temps marché elle se déchargent donc il
faut rester appuyé pour la recharger à
la mer beaucoup plus de trucs que dans
l'ancien à gérer à ce qui vient dire
qu'ils faisaient music box ronde work
des 10 avec ses profits elle est partie
à coup puisque normand il ya une
histoire de batterie mais là je vois pas
la batterie j'ai juste à flash lite donc
là il est 3h du matin voit en haut à
droite et on passe à la nuit suivante
qu'on arrive à 7 heures du matin ok ça
met un petit triangle en bas à droite
quand il faut que je recherche des
boîtes à musique là mais il ya trop de
trucs à gérer non y'a plus lapinous
l'appui nous montre toi lapinou ou va
charger la boîte à musique en attendant
la pipi idéaux
il est pas déjà là non mêlée où on a
perdu l'appétit
il est parti dans le pré comme ça
s'amuser entre le pineau mendy a perdu 2
et ça me rend ouf ils sont où ils sont
il y en a là en bas à gauche on le voit
hockey la boîte à musique yade et
courtois
je peux chez dessus je n'allume
tellement allumé en patois qui est non
il ya un truc arrive là il ya un truc
qui arrive en face mais loger moi si je
garde de match tout le temps je deviens
invincible
gantois regarde je suis un des mains pas
tu tournes humain c'est un petit
concours ils tous payent tout un lapsus
révélateur non mais arrête mais il va
jamais arrêter ce coup là il a la grosse
tête parce qu'il fait la couverture du
jeu sur steam mais ça doit être horrible
quoi ton point de vue vois un mec est
comme ça ah je suis comme toi vraiment
la boîte à musique la boîte à musique
allez on s'en fout au pire au pire en
vrai est un essai c'est un petit et
c'est finalement
et oui je vais approcher la caméra comme
ça je suis plus loin de mon écran et
j'ai moins peur je suis comme toi
n'empêche il ingénieuse gardiens parce
que dans le premier jeu il n'avait pas
cette idée de ce camouflet commun
comment on fait pour qu'il parte faut
tourner le ventilo vers lui il a eu la
peur du vent c'est ça allez on va tenter
mais on peut pas ah bah voilà
oui on et confettis oui il me tend
tellement ce jeu c'est horrible oh
[ __ ] voilà il ya l'autre qui va nous
dire ah là il ya un sixième hausse qui
était arrivé parce qu'on a bien envie de
te tuer ok donc là il est en train de
paris de la nouveauté du fameux masque
qui met pour faire comme si il était
parmi eux
ce truc là voilà et l'autre à me dire
qu'il n'est pas sûr que ça marche pas à
tous les coups bas bien sûr ça marchera
pas à mon gars tu alors il était comme
ça et je suis tendu un peu d'eau un peu
de badauds arrête signal interférer mais
quoi mais maintenant c'est [ __ ] qu'est
nouveau job sciemment dans le dos tu
salis et [ __ ] ils ont fait une
formation avec hayden perdre ils sont
tous partis en même temps m oh non à
l'airbag ya un [ __ ] j'ai mis le masque
un peu chiant ma tablette comme ça
vraiment à ça fait vraiment le mec qui
se camoufle quoi je peux changer les
cadres comme ça au clic en plus on
masque stop à mêler tout froid dans le
mas non c'est un masque un peu un peu
made in china avec des matières à mort
toxiques au hockey c'est pas grave on
reprend à la deuxième nuit c'est parti
les trois sont là là je vous ai dit on
est vraiment bien là on peut voir de la
vraie haute cette fois trois petits
bébés qui dorment deux petits bébés qui
dorment à un petit bébé qui dort au
[ __ ] ok c'est le raccourci focant jab
sûr et je vais quand même pas je veux
pas fait exprès c'est quoi ce bruit
pourquoi les bruits c'est quoi un mec
qui se frotte la tête compte du métal
regarder ce bruit dégueulasse il faut
que je remette un peu de musique un
petit peu de musique pour calmer le jeu
où elle n'a pas le lapin ce fait 20
minutes qu'on a pas vu mon gars alors la
personne personne personne là y'en a
wheel lapin mec non j'appuie sur échappe
j'ai quitté le jeu et ça c'est à cause
de ces deux petites mèches la spat en me
levant je savais qu'elle allait
m'apporter beaucoup de
mauvaise chose par avance sur tout tout
de suite dans quatre minutes voilà cette
fois j'ai juste le petit doigt sur la
touche control ok on a là et ben voilà
bah finalement je vais plus dire qu'on a
c'est pour qu'ils se barrent ce petit
con de merde aux fonderies julien 1
un truc qui pointent momo rythme
cardiaque
il va plus vite que cette musique ça
c'est à cause de cette mèche rebelle et
met toi bien qu'à s'il te plait je sais
que tu as peur aussi mais bon non mais
faut qu'on passe la deuxième nuit quand
même moi pas être ridicule à ce point
fâché quoi je vous mets dans l'histoire
mais c'est moi sais pas vous mais moi je
veux ça me fait me sentir mieux
j'aimerais bien là que toi quérir cette
vidéo je te prête comme ça je te sortent
de l'écran je te mets juste là où même
sur mes genoux comme ça comme ça si j'ai
peur je te tape dans le dos comme sa
part bref on en retient mieux s'il vous
plaît quand même je veux dire c'est pas
comme si y'avait pas de portes pour
bloquer la venue de ces [ __ ] de mons
en fait je pense qu'il faut faire
beaucoup d'un coup d'europe je regarde
s'ils sont pas juste à côté de moi et je
reviens je mets à light of the year soit
juste à côté de moi je reviens jamais
attendez on peut être la lumière dans le
conduit mon gars mais là aussi sur
toutes les gammes en fait on in flash
lite ah ok et du coup ces sacs mais
c'est pour ça que je les voyais jamais
mais voilà tout s'explique
bon après je dis ça ça peut-être pas et
tout se passait comme prévu quand même
et du coup là la barre de flash lite on
va à gauche s'explique
attention on accueille le trio chou ça
des photographes en fait je fais bien ou
pas cet effet un peu de photo
bon j'ai arrêté à mais ouais regarder ça
éclaire la face dans mon moi chaque fois
tout s'explique messieurs dames
un homme et ça en fait c'est même pas un
mec détroit aux [ __ ] je suis avec toi
mais ce qu'il est gentil ou méchant ça
se trouve il c'est pas un méchant en
fait je me dis oh il est juste là mon
gars tu y acheter clerc piaffait que
c'est les psy mtp non non non non non
j'insiste j'insiste j'insiste gens ça a
marché hockey la ruche de professionnels
a marché or ils sont tous là est ce qu
on a un pas loin non apte à part toi
mais surtout bien à ça sent pas bon ça
sent pas bon
je suis avec toi ça se voit quand même
me fais pas ça y est ce la ruse a encore
marché
on y voit que du feu que du petit feu du
pot-au-feu non seb a été interdite par
la loi française
sam temps je suis désolé mais ça me
temps déjà que le niveau je suis gentil
tout plein
hop a lancé des claques doit d harvey
peut-être que ça n'attire et j'en sais
rien faire diversion [ __ ] lala stands
il s'est rapproché pour mieux voir tiens
c'est thomas l'air louche je suis 100%
naturel voilà c'est moi c'est ma peau
comment est ce que je comprends pas
c'est que dans l'ain ce mec veut neymar
ce job
il s'en sort du lot en je me suis coupé
mon ombre dans la dans la peur à
rembourser le pansement j'arrive
vraiment pas je suis tellement paralysé
par la peur des soirées à freddy night
sera interdite par l'os france associe
donc je disais pourquoi ce mec a re
signé un cdd de 1 mois dans cette [ __ ]
de pizzerias alors qu'il a vu dans le
zinc frôlé la mort chaque nuit bordel
photo de famille a brûlé dans la minute
qui suit j'ai reproché la bouteille
d'eau de moi et je me suis mis le
bouchon sur la tête
en tant que je vais me reposer dès 4 ans
bouchon y en a 1 life et la guitare est
maintenant c'est nouveau c'est tout ce
qu'on a peur ok alors tout le monde sur
la cession s'il fait pas je vous ai pas
peur comment comment on le dégage
va-t'en va-t'en deux mois du courage
bouchons donne-moi du courage aux huit
ans je crois que tant qu'il est au fond
ça va c'est quand il s'approche au
premier plan pour l'inspecter de plus
près par toi
en plus fort que moi à quoi je m'énerve
esmod hôpital non oui non mais c'est un
gentil ou méchant je sais pas ok il 3h
du mat
ohlala gardéens pas reconduit jean
encerclé un devant à gauche et à droite
oui où je t'ai eue faut que je recherche
un peu la boîte à musique on est pas mal
on est sur un bon mouvement
non non non non non non et stoi hunan où
nous y aller franchement franchement je
peux lui puisque je me ruine la voie des
jackets la voix j'avais j'étais enfin de
voix cassée un jeu peu plus nord
franchement je suis désolé je peux plus
les gens à gauche mais là le dernier ils
étaient trop trop puissant pour pouvoir
continuer trop puissant pour déjà à dia
pour l'odeur de csl oma voit les gens
c'est à dire 30 cette vidéo je suis
désolé je peux pas continuer j'espère
comme ça vous a plu et vous serez bien
moqué de moi fin ça j'espère pas mais
bon je sais que c'est le cas n'hésitez
pas aimé la vidéo ça vous a plu quand
même tu ne se fera pas au plaisir et
puis on se retrouve très vite dans une
nouvelle vidéo tient tout le monde
pis